the search is on for a hit-and-run
driver who knocked a man off his
motorcycle breaking his collarbone this
all happened on the far east side of
town by d.i and nellis early on saturday
morning orco mana shares the man's plea
to the public in a story you will only
see on 8 news now
jermaine tate was on his motorcycle
going south here on cabana when he says
a driver heading west on desert inn blew
through a red light at this intersection
hit him and then drove off now he's
lucky to be alive i just braced for
impact and i caught the back end of his
car that was the last thing jermaine
tate remembers before he says he was
knocked off his motorcycle by a
hit-and-run driver saturday morning at
desert inn and cabana i just woke up
just this whole side bruised broken
collarbone a police officer at the scene
told him it was likely an impaired
driver who caused the crash and perhaps
more painful than his physical injuries
and concussion is knowing the person
responsible drove away the
accountability part is where i'm heard
at because you clearly hit me and you
kept going without even stop didn't even
break the damage to the motorcycle is
clearly visible and jermaine's wife
melissa tells me she was worried for her
kids if he didn't make it how would he
live without him you know she is
thankful he's still here and she has a
message for whoever did this if you
wouldn't hit and run and leave your
child on the ground like that
don't do it to somebody else
because it doesn't just impact them it
impacts their whole family jermaine
knows he's one of the lucky ones we've
seen motorcycles get hit and don't come
home thank god that i got the next
chance to do that metro police say they
are investigating this hit-and-run crash
reporting in las vegas orco mana live
local now